or other top story tonight another
unusual Discovery is Lake Mead's
Shoreline continues to recede this time
it's only about a 100 yards from where a
body washed up along Hemingway Harbor
back in May so could these two actually
be connected Sasha Loftus spoke with the
woman who made the discovery tonight
joining us in studio with more Brian and
Denise the woman I spoke with says
finding something like this was really
surreal she and her colleague were here
from New York to report on Lake Mead and
the severe drought but they didn't
expect to become part of the story
the mystery of Lake Mead's shrinking
Shoreline continues to unfold sort of a
rush of course to to see that we had
found a gun this week journalist Emily
Svenson became part of its latest
chapter when she and her colleague
discovered a gun in a spot that was once
hidden under water we sort of stumbled
across this Con The Contours of a gun
and it was sort of buried in the sand it
was about 100 yards from where this body
was found in a barrel back in May so the
question keeps coming back could there
be a connection to organized crime
historically there isn't a great
connection between the lake and the mob
Jeff Schumacher of the Mob Museum says
the mafia wasn't known to dump weapons
here but anything is possible there
could be many guns in the bottom of Lake
Mead it just has never been a story
before Dive Master Melanie Dennen has
now ever seen anything like this but
says as severe drought continues this
Lake could be hiding a lot more the
bottom of Lake Mead is
um it's really soft there's a lot of mud
and silt so stuff will sink down into
the mud and you can't even see it and
while Emily came here to tell a story
this find made her wonder if we've even
really scratched the surface we'll see
what what other secrets Lake Mead holds
Melanie says regardless of where this
gun came from it's rare to find a weapon
like this underwater Metro Police say
while there is no known connection to
the body discovered in a barrel they are
not ruling this out Brian Sasha thank
you and more human remains were found at
the lake this week Jesus Catalan finding
skeletal remains for now the second time
on Monday he found what he believes to
be a leg bone and neck bone in the swim
Beach area near Hemingway Harbor he went
on to say that he found remains back in
July which have also been confirmed to
be human
thank you